everyone says go to college get a job
but what if you want more out of life
than just a job
what if you want meaning purpose and
fulfillment in your work
your relationships and every other area
of life
what kind of education would you need
for that kind of life
today the typical college experience is
a narrow path
pick a major focus your studies on one
specific field or profession
and at the end you're ready for that one
field or profession
at hillsdale we offer a different kind
of education
a classical liberal arts education
studying the liberal arts creates a
foundation for a liberated life
a life that's free and able to be lived
well
we do this at hillsdale through a core
curriculum designed to pursue what is
good
true and beautiful every student at
hillsdale spends their first two years
together
immersed in this core curriculum made up
of the humanities
the social sciences and the natural
sciences
you'll still choose a major but because
of this core curriculum
that major will be built on a deep
understanding of the nature of the world
and the nature of humanity practically
you'll learn to think deeply and
critically
to solve complex problems and to write
and speak effectively
skills that are invaluable in any job
and in every area of life
ultimately a classical liberal arts
education at hillsdale
means you won't just be ready for a job
or career you'll be ready for a good
life hillsdale this is what college is
meant to be